what are some things that you as a man
would advise new moms to instill in
their young Sons to be later good men I
think spending time with them one-on-one
as they get a little bit older you know
as they get to be like five six seven
eight
uh spend some time just separately go do
something separate with your son
you know one of the only things ever got
to do with my mom that was just me and
her
was uh
we went to Wendy's one time
and I know that doesn't sound like a lot
but and I probably have talked about
this before but um you know my mother
worked all the time
you know she didn't want us to be on
welfare so she worked and I'm not saying
that she's better than your mom I'm not
saying that she's better than your
grandmother she's any day I'm not saying
anything like that I'm just saying that
and I think she works sometimes too
because she was probably stressed out
from having four children she didn't
know what else to do maybe sometimes so
she did what she knew how to do which
was to work
but one time I was sick or something I
couldn't be at school I could have
gotten you know expelled maybe or not
expelled but suspended
and so I had to go to work with my mom
and we rode around it's like different
cities or whatever we're delivering like
magazines who was delivering magazines
at the time
and we're delivering these magazines and
it was just kind of cool because I got
to be with her
it was just me and her and we went to
Wendy's for lunch and I'd never went to
a lunch place just with me and my mom
before
you know and
um
and we we uh there was too long of a
line inside so we went through the
drive-through and we got sandwiches and
we just rode around and ate them
and I'm sure I was probably an
that day but you know it was a typical
kid but I looking back I remembered as
like one of my favorite times where I
got to spend time with just me and my
mother so I would just make sure that
you know or I don't know make sure I
don't have a family but I think that
that's important to make sure there's
some connection there try not to tell
your son he don't always want to hear
what
what will do better sometimes he just
wants you to love him and just let him
know that he's okay
um and to
you know let him know that you love him
that's it
you know sometimes a kid doesn't always
hear how it could be better or how he
could have done it different or what
because they don't
they don't that's that's adult stuff
you know and I've struggled with that
over my life telling people what could
they could do better
you know sometimes people just want to
hear that they're not alone and
especially your kid will your son will
want to hear that
um
and then I would take some control and I
would I would talk to him about how he
treats women
because I don't think that's a
conversation that just
men need to have with their sons anymore
I do think that that's a conversation
that women need to have and I commend
you I think that the the toughest thing
a woman can do is uh be a mom and to
manage the home and to take the risk of
there being less income in the home to
stay at home and create that family
but if we can get out of what the world
tells us is good and we can get back
into what our heart tells us is right or
good I'm not going to say right that's
not the word but feels good
then I think you know we'll find a lot
of times that it's that it's that that
it's being with our family you know and
having those fun times and having those
um you know ridiculous my favorite time
that I ever had when I was young was
when the power went out and my family
would all be together
and we couldn't fight or beat each other
because they had candles lit and it's
dangerous to beat each other around
candles
so we would just be together
and we were kind of scared and nervous
but we were all together like in one
place you know my mom had two candles
and so we would have to be by her we
would have to be together
and it was just I don't know it was
something special about that
so you know uh
I think those are a few things
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one